demolition good morning Hank it's Monday
so since people inside are currently
demolishing my house I'm filming in my
front yard
okay Hank today's video comes to you in
four parts part one page rail stone
she's real that's right Hank
nerdfighters have successfully convinced
the BOTS at twenty qnet that page rail
stone is a real person
god I love nerdfighters part two
speaking of the awesome of nerdfighters
I get to announce some new Ning masters
so Hank senior executive Ning Master Tom
has recruited some new Ning masters they
are forum Ning masters eric and chris
images Ning Master Kate aka Team Unicorn
showing that just because I hate
unicorns doesn't mean I don't love
people who love unicorns the new chat
Ning masters are kooky and Shaun and for
the first time we've got a wiki Ning
master Jake that's right Hank we're
relaunching the wiki wiki wookie
nerdfighters if you want to contribute
to the wiki and we really need you to
you can go to wiki Brotherhood to calm
the books Ning master is going to be 10
we Nadine the blogs Ning master is now
Sarah aka cleverest witch our anti world
suck Ning master is Annika and our
official Ducky's Ning master is Ashley I
don't know why we have an official
Ducky's Ning master but we do part three
nerdfighter gatherings Hank nerdfighters
who live in or around the Bay Area
should go to an awesome nerdfighter
gathering on October 10th nerdfighters
are getting together for a fundraiser
for shawn Achmed's uncultured project
also wheezy waiters Driftless Pony Club
will be playing it's gonna be so awesome
I wish I could be there but since I
can't hopefully many of you will more
info in the sidebar I'm pointing in the
wrong direction dang it
finally part for the winners of the
Paper Towns paperbacks Hank I have ten
winners left to announce first the
winner of the song challenge is mash TVP
10 for his awesome paper town songs
there were a lot of great songs and I
hated to choose just one but in the end
I had to 10-word common winners Soul
tapestry when the wall is gone where
will Willy hide his victims Willy where
do you keep the bodies
he's not talking lemons 3 4 9 all your
paperback paper towns are belong to us
they are 1 3 9 going naked under your
graduation robe can never end well which
is really one of the main lessons I was
trying to impart when writing Paper
Towns meowy three unicorns were totally
left off the ark for a reason amen
pineapple riot oh noes I'm wielding your
guitar killing all your fascists if only
Woody Guthrie could have known that one
day I would use a line of his in a book
of mine that would be turned into
lolspeak by a reader our p.m. 2004 diary
Sunday September 13th talked about
sports and hidden testicles fangirl of
awesome wins for a video in which she
explains the story behind the following
10 word comment sad Margo is sad because
happy Margo has been eaten boon VT Paper
Towns in your pants chafes but still
reads well and the last winner is floor
win who writes don't worry Hank my
little ponies is a legit obsession don't
listen to her Hank it isn't I'm sorry if
you didn't win one of the books there
were more than 15,000 entries which
means you only had a one in 1,000 chance
of winning so hopefully you won't be mad
at me and you'll still consider getting
the book winners email me your address
hank dftba now let's listen to some of
that great song of the night but I can
see her almost perfectly in the correct
and fading
you've been hiding in a favorite town
for weeks without anyone else or color
in your cheeks you've been hiding for me
and that favorite town for weeks and
there's nothing I won't do find that
favorite sound and you
[Music]
to find that paper town
you